hello i'm alex arnold and this is
climbing support with wired
[Music]
question from david sandal sandel
perhaps what's your favorite type of
climbing hold pinch crimp slope slab
heel hook tow hook jam or drop knee drop
some of those aren't even climbing holds
but who cares he just named
all kinds of fancy climbing words and i
will show you how to do all these fancy
techniques on a climbing gym wall
check it out pinches are as you would
expect just pinching with your hand
crimps it means like an edge that you
then bring your thumb over your fingers
and pull really hard slopes or just
anything you know where your hand is
sort of open a heel hook isn't really a
hold either but it's just something you
can put your heel on toe hooking is
something that you hook your toe on
pretty straight forward jamming is just
any time you put your hands or your feet
or even your elbow or whatever else into
a crevice and jam it into place uh knee
dropping brits call it an egyptian you
know because you turn all hieroglyphic
style you know i like pinches i like big
limestone i like tufas that's like a
type of limestone pinch but i like gram
salt like so you know i kind of like it
all it really depends on how clean the
rock is and how aesthetic the line is
and how how flowy the climbing is
question from glenn holland why are
yellow holes always the little crimpy
suckers or the slimy slopers that is a
fair question i don't know why the
yellow holes always suck it's like
always the little little fierce little
guys i don't know why but somebody
decided the yellow would be hard and it
is
here's a question from
queen cooking have you climbed cracks i
found gloves made for crack climbing
interested in different opinions some
considered to be cheating you've got to
have pain you don't have to endure pain
if you don't want to gloves protect
against rock abrasion i think what she's
getting at is that a lot of people think
that it's cheating to use crack gloves
but i think i naturally have kind of
thick skin and so it's not as big an
issue for me i do actually think for
beginners it's probably better to use
crack gloves or tape or something to
protect their hands and learn good
technique to begin with i'm going to
show you how to crack climb in the gym
which basically just means very
carefully good technique in crack
climbing is putting your hand into the
crack locking it into place and then not
having it slide or move nothing like
passing blood stains next to the crack
you know that you're doing it right
people tear holes in their skin when
their hand slides out of the crack or if
it gives but if you can place it in and
exert enough pressure in the one spot it
won't cut your skin unless you slide out
of the jam next question from jay do all
rock climbers live in vans hashtag free
solo no so not all rock climbers live in
vans and i lived in a tent with a
bicycle for a while before and i didn't
have a car for a while but i think that
living in a van is definitely a nice way
to live as a rock climber because it
allows you a lot of the comfort of a
home but with the flexibility of
traveling non-stop to get to good
climbing areas and follow good weather
but no i mean a lot of climbers live out
of the back of trucks some live out a
friend of mine who's a professional
climber lived out of a honda civic for
many years which is pretty scrappy but
uh but he did just fine next question
from mike ball anyone have advice on how
to keep my forearms from filling with
blood and losing my grip during hashtag
bouldering or hashtag rock climbing what
he's asking is how do you keep from
getting pumped when you climb the only
real way to do that is just to to build
up more fitness and if you are in the
middle of a climb and you find that your
arms are really really pumped then you
kind of just have to find a hole that's
big enough for you to recover on so i'll
show you now in a climbing gym how i
would recover which is basically just
finding a big hole and hanging from it
one-handed sort of relax the other hand
just let your muscles relax some people
find like shaking it helps other people
find that just letting it dangle helps
or just taking deep breaths if you've
never practiced resting then you won't
be able to recover even on a really big
hole question hey alex you climbed el
capita he forgot the end i want to know
how you just remain focused rather than
being afraid of the height i mean he
really wants to know how i climbed el
capitan he should just watch the film
free solo because it's a pretty pretty
good coverage of the two years of
practice and preparation and training
that i put into actually climbing it i
don't know there's a lot to unpack in
that question but i mean i think in
general it's easy to remain focused when
your life is on the line you know
question from nicole van den brook once
you got to the top question mark how did
you get down question mark another
easier path for abseiling and how did
the whole crew get there so fast and no
water drinks on the whole climb of free
solo basically she wants to know about
the logistics of freestyling cap to get
down from the top el cap you can walk
down the side and then you do a little
bit of repelling at the end of it so the
whole crew hiked up that way yeah it's
funny how did the crew get there so fast
they would probably argue that it took
him a long time i mean it takes a couple
hours to walk up there and it's very
hard work and they have heavy backpacks
on it's you know feels like a lot of
toil and there were water drinks on the
climb i stashed water and food in two
places on the route both big natural
ledges one a thousand feet off the
ground and the other one about 2000 feet
off the ground so kind of broke the
route into thirds so i was able to
relax in a couple places it's just not
shown in the film because you know it's
a 90 minute documentary that covers two
years of my life so it's hard to show
everything question from dominic alex if
you can remember i'd love to know the
mystery meal you cooked in free solo i
know consider eggs spicy canned chili
spinach and some crunchy vegetable
i can't be the only one who wants to try
it best documentary mystery meal i think
the meal that he's referring to was was
sort of an egg scramble i think i did
sweet potatoes and maybe an onion sort
of grilled them up and then added eggs
and then probably well apparently canned
chili and maybe spinach on top as well
but basically it's just me mixing all
the vegetables in my van together and
adding some eggs and making it delicious
question from dave barker how do rock
climbers get their ropes back when
coming down must cost them a fortune i
don't totally even know where to start
with that so um so normally you climb up
to an anchor it's a fixed anchor on the
wall there are carabiners or chains or
something attached to the wall
permanently and then you just lower back
down from those and when you get to the
ground you just untie your knot you pull
the rope back down everything comes down
it's no problem your ropes don't really
cost a fortune typically you know your
rope will last for years and you use it
over and over from beachchicken.etsy
am going into a rock climbing today it
should be very interesting what does one
wear rock climbing need advice i think
you can wear
anything
i mean wear exercise clothes wear yoga
clothes where pajamas you know
whatever's comfortable if you wear tight
jeans you might not be able to put your
feet where you need to
i'm joining a rock climbing gym any
advice on equipment to get just basics i
think you basically need shoes harness
and chalk bag and a belay device and
then eventually maybe a rope or
depending on the gym even just shoes in
a chalk bag would be enough or if you're
feeling really cheap just shoes and then
borrow other people's chalk climbing
shoes affect your performance as a
climber more than any other piece of
equipment here's a question from your
girl katie how does one get over the
fear of falling when bouldering i fell
once and almost busted my leg so now i'm
afraid to boulder without being worried
about falling tips i think that that to
feel comfortable falling you have to
trust that you're not going to get hurt
when you fall and i think that that
trust needs to be built up over time now
i'm going to show how i fall in a
bouldering gym which honestly i don't
know if it's the best way but i have
been falling this way for 20 years and
you know i generally don't get hurt so
we'll see you know there are a few
basics in how to fall well while bowling
landing on your feet ideally and then
sort of rolling backward dispersing the
force not putting your hands behind you
not landing too crooked or anything but
i think that if you have some kind of an
accident you know it takes a while to
build confidence back up after that so i
think that an obvious way would be to
sort of start small take very small
falls you know fall with a lot of
control and sort of build back up but
know that the gym is made for you to be
safe so you should be okay that said i
have broke my arm in the gym
how do rock climbers get the ropes tied
to the top so they can use the ropes to
climb
things i ponder i'm curious what other
things they ponder so most rock climbers
don't get the rope tied to the top most
climbers climb from the bottom and they
clip the rope into protection as they go
so sometimes they carry equipment with
them and place it in the cracks
sometimes the equipment's already in
situ
and they just have to clip it but one
way or another people normally start
from the bottom and then climb upward
and clip in as they go and so it's kind
of up to them to make sure that they
stay safe alex honold is a god and
psychopath all in one he's on some
transcendental level type chisel i'll
just edit that how does he do that what
happens if he sneezes on the cliff i
don't even know where to go with that so
if i sneeze on the cliff i fall to my
death you know so i just make sure that
my sinuses are totally clear before i
climb every time
no that's i don't know i mean if you
sneeze you sneeze i don't know it's like
when you're driving on the highway if
you sneeze are you instantly going to
die it's like probably not you just stay
straight and sneeze i don't think i'm on
any transcendental level stuff we'll
just
i don't think he quite gets it here's a
question from a dude whose name i can't
read but he asks how many pull-ups can
an elite rock climber bang out i think
that's a very wide range i think that
most climbers can probably do you know
at least 20 pull-ups maybe but i know a
few professional climbers who you know
can't do that many pull-ups i can only
do a handful but they have freakishly
strong fingers and that's kind of enough
to hang onto the rock and then they also
have really good technique i'll do a few
pull-ups on a bowling wall just to show
that i can do them so i'm going to bet
that i can do at least 10.
really the number of pull-ups you can do
doesn't necessarily correlate to how
well you can climb but i'm definitely
not maxing out because i'd rather save
my energy for actual climbing question
from dan what's a good beginner guide to
hangboard training do you still use them
hashtag rock climbing i think as a
beginner you probably shouldn't worry
about hang boarding that much if you
just started climbing having really
strong arms and strong fingers isn't
really the most important thing you want
to focus on your footwork you want to
work on technique you want to learn how
to move your body well and i think that
hang boarding becomes more of a useful
training tool as you get more advanced
in climbing but i think if you're a
beginner and you really want to train on
hangboard then you should focus on
bodyweight hangs and start very gently
question from the atheist officiant
alexander any chance you will be in
tokyo for the 2020 games wife and i are
having a great conversation about the
different types of climbing how gym is
different than rock we want to hear your
thoughts on olympic climbing so there is
a chance that i'll be in tokyo for the
20 20 games not competing however maybe
doing some commentating or talking about
it because i really want to watch but it
is true that the gym climbing and
olympic style climbing is fundamentally
different than rock climbing
particularly on big walls like in
yosemite so the people who are currently
qualifying for the olympics and will be
competing in the olympics are for the
most part teenagers and in the way that
olympic level gymnasts are mostly from
the age of say 15 to maybe 21 or
something so by that standard i'm way
over the hill and i'm yeah i'm way past
my prime timing-wise the people who are
going to be winning the olympics are
focused on training in the gym but to
climb something like el capitan you
spend all your time outside adventuring
and hiking it's just totally different
arenas here's one of elon musk have you
reached out to alex honold about a
climbing trip to mars and so just in
case elon's listening to this i would
love to go you just say the word
this is climate support with wired i
hope you learned something and thanks
for watching